[موسيقى]
الحصاد معكم جلال شهد في الوقت الذي
احدثكم فيه احداث تقع وتتفاعل اخرى
الانذار مساء اليوم في وقت ان تستمر فيه
المعارك في الجنوب والشرق على واقع مساعد
الدفع
وتصلنا هذه الصور من صحه سمرتين في قلبه
لما عاصمه برو حيث ينظم انصار رئيس
الياسمين مخلوع قدركاستينو احتجاجات يوميه
على لطاحه به وتعيين نائبته خلف لهم
[موسيقى]
ونختم من لندن مع هذه الصور والامال التي
تحملها نتائج تجربه علاج جديد لنوع
الفتاكه من سرطان الدم باستخدام خلايا
مناعيه معدله وراثيه وراثيه
في مواضيع الحصاد
[موسيقى]
مع استمرار المعارك على جبهات عده في
اوكرانيا زنسكي يتمسك بالنقاط العشري
تحقيق السلام وقصيغه الاوكرانيه لندن تحذر
من استغلال روسيا محادثات السلام كغطاء
لاعاده تسلحها ومسك تقول ان السبب الحرب
هو تجاهلها وجسها الامنيه وتؤكد ان عدوها
ليس في اكياف بل في الغرب
قبل يومين من اجتماع الحاسمي لوزاره
الطاقه الاوروبيين اردوغان يبحث مع بوتنا
المصالحه المشتركه في مجال الطاقه وان شاء
الله مركز اقليميا في اسطنبول لتصدير
الغاز وابورال يبدي قلقه الاتحاد الاوروبي
من سياسه تركيا في عدم الانضمام للاجراءات
التقليديه الاوروبيه ضد روسيا
على واقع التشديد القوات التركيه قصفها في
شمال سوريا الازمه تتصدر اتصالا بين
الرئيسين التركي والروسي انقره تطلب من
موسكو تطهير الحدود السوريه مع تركيا بعمق
كلملا يقولوا ان الرئيسين بحث حلا نزاع
على اساس اتفاق في 2019
وسط تصاعد التوتر بين الاقليه الصربيه
والسلطات في شمال
محتمله على البعثه الاوربيه
واشنطن تدعو الى ضبط النفس والرئيس الصربي
يعقد اجتماعا طارئا لمجلس الامن القومي
في لقاءنا يومين قبل الحصاد على الناصره
من الرقميه ناقشنا تاهل منتخب المغرب لنصف
نهائي كاس العالم لكره القدم قطر 2022 في
انجازا هو الاول من نوعه لاي منتخب عربي
او افريقي وبعد تاهلهم التاريخي على حساب
البرتغال سيواجه اللاعبون المغاربه اسود
الاطلس منتخبه فرنسا في دوري الاربعه
لاستطلاع رايكم بشان هذا الموضوع طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي في اعتقادكم ما هي
فرصه المغرب للفوز بكاس العالم قطر
202253% قالوا ان فرص الفوز كبيره بينما
قال 34% ان الفرص محدوده اما 13% فيعتقدون
ان فرص فوز المغرب بكاس العالم معدومه هذا
سؤال سيبقى مطروحا في منصاتنا الرقميه
يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
الظاهري على الشاشه لقاءنا على منصات
الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ولا نتطرق خلاله
لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيه
تتابعونا في الحصاد ايضا
بعد تعافي طفله بريطانيه من سرطان الدم
اثر مشاركتها في تجربه طبيه علماء يكشفون
عن علاج غير مسبوق هو الاكثر تطورا
باستخدام تقنيه التعديل الوراثي للخلايا
المناعيه
بعد الحصاد مباشره وتحديدا في الساعه
12:50 دقائق بتوقيت مكه المكرمه تتابعون
الجوله الرياضيه اليوميه يوميات المونديال
التي ترصد بالخبر والتحليل مباريات كاس
العالم قطر 2022
[موسيقى]
مواساتي صوت المدافع والانفشارات في
اوكرانيا ثم تصريحات وتلميحات على علاقه
بتهدئه وتفاوض محتمل على لساني اكثر من
مسؤول غربي ومن الاوكرانيين وروسيا انفسهم
وتبدو عوامل متداخله وراء امكانيه حدوث
اختراق في جدار الحرب التي تقترب من اكمال
شهرها العاشر
خيرسون بيكو لايف اوديسي وعلى الجانب
الاخر
مديره الاستخبارات الامريكيه القتال في
اوكرانيا خلال الاشهر المقبله بسبب ما
سيفرده الشتاء المقبل من بيئه مختلفه
على اكثر من اللسان في تغريده على تويتر
اتهم مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني الرئيس
الروسي بانه غير قادر على التفاوض المتحدث
باسم الكرم رغم الكره في ملعب الطرف الاخر
فبرر حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا بتجاهل
الهواء الروسيه بشان اتفاقيات مصر اذا
هناك ما يمكن اصلاحها اما وزير الخارجيه
البريطاني فقال ان اي محادثه سلام في
اوكرانيا يجب ان لا تستخدم غطاء لتسلح
روسيا وان بلاده لم تلاحظ اي اشارات بان
بوتين مستعد للدخول في محادثه سلام بحسن
نيه بينما اعرب الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان في اتصال الهاتف مع نظيره الروسي
عن امله بانهاء الحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا
في اقرب وقت ممكن امال معلنه تتزامن مع
دعوه الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون الى
منح موسكو ضمانات امنيه ايجاد توازن معها
في حال عدت الى التفاوض وهي الدعوه التي
جاءت بعد زيارته الى واشنطن مكرونه
الاساسيه هي الخوف من ان ياتي حلف النيه
الى ابوابها ونشر اسلحه يمكن ان تهددها
ولا تغيب عن هذه الامال تصريحات المستشار
الالماني
بان من المهم ابقاء قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه
مع الرئيس الروسي لتحينا لحظه انهاء الحرب
وجاء اعلان الرئيس الامريكي
لمناقشه روسيا بشان امكانيه انهاء الى عمل
القتاليه على ان تتخذ قرارات معينه لسحب
قواتها من اوكرانيا ليعزز من زخم امكانيه
اختراق في جدار الحرب المستمر كل هذه
التطورات تاتي بينما تبدلت روسيا
واوكرانيا 120 اسيرا في اطار صفقه جديده
بين الجانبين وفي مكالمه مع ماكرون قال
رئيس الاوكراني ان هناك شمعه معاهده
السلام من 10 نقاط وفق الصيغه الاوكرانيه
وان المواقف بين كيف وباريس متقاربه تتضمن
المعاهده بنودا بينها الامن النووي
والسعاده وحده الاراضي الاخرانيه وامن
الطاقه وعوده وجميع اسرى الحرب المحتجزين
في روسيا وفياف اما من وجهه نظر روسيا فان
التفاوض بدا يبدا من اعتراف بجمهوريه
لوغانسكو ودونيس وسيادته روسيا على شبه
جزيره القرم وتخلي اوكرانيا مستقبل عن
الاسلحه النوويه وعدم طرقها ابواب حلف
النيته في المنظور القدير
نقش الموضوع مع ضيفينا من موسكو الدكتور
السنه الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه ومن
باريس السيناتور جيلبر روجيه نائب رئيس
لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه والدفاع والقوات
المسلحه في مجلس الشيوخ الفنسي مرحبا
بكماه السيد روجيه ابدا معك هل باتت دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اكثر قناعه بضروره بدء مسار
تفاوضين لانهاء الحرب معزل عن الوضع
الميداني
ايه القمر
بدا مفاوضات هذا سيكون ممكن ان عندما
يقوم السيد بوتين بحركه قويه مثلا وقفه
اطلاق النار بدون شروته بشكل فوري مما
يسمحوا الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات
المتحده بان تفهم وكذلك بلدان الشرق
الاوسط ان تفهم ان سيد بوتين يريد
تنظيمه
مفاوضات سلام
لا يبدو بان الرئيس بوتين همم سينهي الحرب
الدخول بمفاوضات بينما نسمع تصريحات غربيه
ومنها للرئيس مكروه عن ضروره اعطاء ضمانات
لروسيا مقابل عودتها لطاوله كيف نفهم ماذا
نعم ولكن
الضمانات
لكي يمكننا ان نعطيها ينبغي اولا ان يقوم
السيد بوتين يقدم هو
الضمانات لانه هو المعتدي
الجنود في الجبهات خاصه الجبهات الشرقيه
والجنوبيه
وعدم قدره الجيش الاوكراني على مزيد من
التقدم واسترداد المناطق التي سيطرت عليها
روسيا هل يفتح فرصه
لبدء مسار تفوتي بتقديرك
لا اعتقد انا عائد من واشنطن حيث يناقشنا
مع الامريكيين وكذلك مع الاوكرانيين
وفي الوقت الحاضر
ليس هناك وضع على الارض
الروس
له سابقا ولكن حتى الرئيس الامريكي
قال بانه مستعد للحديث مع الرئيس الروسي
ولكن يبدو ان روسيا غير مستعده
لانهاء الحرب اذا ما نقالات هذا السباق ما
بين الحرب على الارض
والتصريحات بضروره انهاء هذه الحرب بمفاوض
بمسار تفوضي سيد
التي تدرس الموقف الروسي
اذا كنت اقول ان الموقف الروسي هو الذي
يستمر في استهداف المدنيين من اجل تدمير
جميع المنشات
البنيه التحتيه في من الكهرباء ومدارس
ومستشفيات وهذه ليست علامات
ومؤشرات على الرغبه في وضع حد لهذه الحرب
عديمه الجدوى والتي لن يفوز فيها احد شكرا
لك اسرته جيلبر روجينا الرئيس سجده الشؤون
الخارجيه والدفاع والقوات المسلحه في مجلس
الشيوخ الفرنسي الدكتور سانسلاف همم دائما
يردد الغرب بان روسيا ليست مستعده للبدء
بمصار تفاضلي نظرا للواقع على الارض
وعدم قدره روسيا حتى الان على الاقل على
استعاده المناطق التي خسيرتها لصالح الجيش
الاوكراني هل ممكن ان تكون روسيا اكثر
استعدادا لبدا هكذا مسار
يمكنها ان تبدا في مصاري المفاوضات اذا ما
قامت الدول الاوروبيه
وطبعا اوكرانيا بالعربي
انه من الصعوبه الى القوات الروسيه
والقوات الاوكرانيه على السوائل التقدم
ميدانيه نحن نعرف ان روسيا تسيطر على شبه
جزيره القرموكرانيا تقول انها تود ان
تستعيد هذه الاراضي ولكن وزير الخارجيه
دعونا نتذكر ما قال تحدثت عن شروط فبراير
2022 هذه الاراضي التي ذكرها وبالتالي
روسيا كانت قد سيطرت على القرن قبل ذلك
باضافه الى ذلك
همم من شهر تقريبا قال انه على الارجح ان
الاوان بنسبه الى اوكرانيا كي تدخل في
مسار تفاوضي لانها حقت اكثر ما يمكن ان
يحقق حتى اللحظه الراهنه الدول الغربيه لن
تساعد اوكرانيا كي تستعيد السيطره على
القرن وحتى ايدهم باص لذلك بعد اشهر
سوف يستمر الوضع الميدانيه على حاله
ولربما المفاوضات يمكن ان تبدا في غيابي
تغير ميداني اذا ما تمكنت روسيا
اوكرانيا من تحقيق تقدمات الميدانيه لربما
هذا سوف يؤجل المفاوضات ولكن اعتقد انه من
الواقعي بالنسبه الى الاوكرانيا ان تستعيد
السيطره على الاراضي بنسبه الى روسيا
يدعونا نتذكر ما قاله السيد قال ان روسيا
تسيطر على اراضي اضافيه وايضا بحر ازوف هو
بحر روسيا داخلي الان وهذا يمكن ان يقدم
الى الشعب
الروسيكا نتيجه ايجابيه لهذه الحمله
الروسيه الروس يستمعون همم الى هذا الخطاب
ان همم
نفهم منك بان الماسق الحالي للطرفين للطرف
الاوكراني والطرف الروسي ميدا طبعا نتحدث
اا قد يعجل من بدا مسار تفوضى تتواتر
تصريحات غربيه بخصوصه
اي التغيرات في الجبهات القتاليه على
الارجح يمكن ان تبدا المفاوضات ماذا
يمكننا ان نتوقع غير ذلك اذا ما لم يتم
تحقيق اي تقدم ميدانيه اذا من وجهه نظري
المشكله الوحيده بالنسبه الى
المفاوضات هي موقف الحكومه الاوكرانيه
الرئيس
قال في خطاب رسمي انه يود ان يستعيد
السيطره على
القرمسك اذا ما اراد ان يقوم بذلك انا
متاكد من ان الرئيس يقدم له هذه الاراضي
اذا ما قامت اوكرانيا بمحاوله اجتياح
القرب بمساعده الغرب سوف نصل الى ازمه
النوويه لذلك الخيار الوحيد بنسبه الى
المفاوضات هو
تغيير في موقف زيلانسكي بنسبه الى شكرا
القرمباس شكرا لك الدكتور خوفيتش الباحث
في العلاقات الدوليه في موسكو
شدد منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جونكوربي على
نواشنطن لا تشجع العمليات الاوكرانيه داخل
الاراضي الروسيه واضاف كربي في مقابله مع
شبكه اي بي سي الامريكيه ان دعم بلاده
الاكياس يهدف لتعزيز قدره الاوكرانيين على
الدفاع عن اراضيهم
نحن بالتاكيد لا نشجع العمليات الاوكرانيه
داخل روسيا نحن نحاول التاكد من انهم
يستطيعون الدفاع عن مناطقهم واستعاده
اراضيهم ومنذ البدايه حدثنا عن ضروره
الوعي بمخاطر تصعيد هذه الحرب لا لان هذا
ليس جيدا للشعب الاوكراني فقط انه ليس
جيدا للمصالحنا وليس جيدا ايضا لشعب
الروسي
ورغم الحديث عن فرص لتسويه السلميه فان
المعارك مستمره على جبهات عديده فماذا عن
تطورات الحرب والتحولات في الاهداف
المعلنه بشانها نطرح السؤال على ضيف
الحصاد لاحقا في فقره المتابعه
[موسيقى]
موضوع اخر هذه صله في خضم تداعيه ازمه
الغاز في القاره الاوروبيه بحث الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في اتصال هاتفيه
مع نظيره
الغازي في منطقه اسطنبول ياتي هذا الاتصال
قبيل الاجتماعي لوزاره الطاقه في دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي سيناقش الخلافات بشان
وضع سقف لسعر الغزل الروسي ضمن المساعي
الاوروبيه للتضييق اقتصاديا على بوتن بسبب
حربه على اوكرانيا
ترغب موسكو انقره في المضيء قدمنا
لتصدير الغاز في تركيا فكان ذلك من ابرز
ما تحدث بشانه رئيس البلدين في مكالمته
الهاتفيه
واستغلال الموقع الاستراتيجي للبلد بين
اوروبا واسيا الوسطى والشرق الاوسط لتحويل
تركيا
اقل تصل عبر الانابيب العابره الى القاره
الاوروبيه من اوكرانيا وبلغاريا تقدر باقل
من 10% تستهلكه دول القاره
جمع الرئيس التركي بالرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
غاز بروما الروسيه اكد اردوغان خلاله ان
البلدان سيعملان فورا على تنفيذ مقترح
بوتين لنقل الغاز الروسي عبر تركيا الى
القاره الاوروبيه
بعين الريبه ينظر مفوض السياسه الخارجيه
للاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل الى هذا
التقرب التركي الروسي فقد قال ان عدم
استعداد تركيا للانضمام الى العقوبات
الغربيه على روسيا مدعاه للقلق
لا تخفى معالم ازمه الغاز التي ما فتئت
تهدد شتاء الاوروبيين رغم استمرار مساؤهم
للتضييق على الصادرات الروسيه على خلفيه
حرب اوكرانيا حتى في ظل حاجتهم الماسه
للغاز الروسيه
الطاقه لدول الاتحاد الاوروبي في اجتماعهم
المقرر الثلاثاء المقبل حيث سيناقشون سقفا
لسعر الغازي الروسي واستنقسام بين الدول
الاعضاء تقول الدول المؤيده لسقف اسعار
الغاز ان هذا الاجراء سيحمي اقتصاداتها من
ارتفاع تكاليف الطاقه لكن دول مهمه مثل
المانيا وهولندا تعارض ذلك
ليس الوقت المتاح امام الاوروبيين طويله
فها هي ايام الشتاء حلت او تكاد لكن
خيارات تعويض الغاز الروسي ما زالت غير
كافيه قال الكريم لن تعليقا على ذلك ان
الدول الاوروبيه الراغبه في التخلي عن
اعتمادها على الغاز الروسي اصبحت تعتمد
على الغاز الامريكي المسال واضاف انهم
سيخسرون بذلك مليارات اليورو يوميا وهو ما
ستستفيد منه واشنطن فتكلفه الغاز المسال
قد ترهق ميزانيه هذه الدول اذا استغنت به
عن كميات مهمه من الغاز الروسي القادم عبر
الانابيب بتكلفه منخفضه
وفي واشنطن قال المنسق الرئاسي الامريكي
الخاص للطاقه الدوليه
لا يزال مشاكل تهديدا لسوق النفط الشديده
التقلب واتهما هوكستين في مقابله مع صحيفه
الفايننشيل تايمز روسيا باستخدام الطاقه
سلاحا اكثر من مره بما في ذلك اغلاق
امدادات الغاز عن المانيا قائلا ان خطر
وقف روسيا لامدادات النفط يبقى قائما سواء
وضع سقف للاسعار ام لم يوضع ورجحه هوشتين
حدوث مزيدا من الاضطرابات في اسواق الطاقه
العالميه لاسيما سوق الغاز في اوروبا مع
تعمق المواجهه بين بوتن والغرب
من جانب الاخر اجرى الرئيس الاوكراني ضمير
زينسكي محادثه هاتفيه مع نظيره التركيه
رجب طيب اردوغان واشار زنسكي الى دعم
تركيا لمبادره الحبوب الاوكرانيه كما ناقش
الرئيسان سبل توسعه اتفاقيه ممر الحبوب
الاوكرانيه الى العالم وذكر زينسكي عبر
حسابه في تلجرام انه شكر نظيره التركيه
على ايواء الاطفال الاوكرانيين وارسال
مئات من مولدات الكهرباء الى المدن
الاوكرانيه
اعلنت اداره الموارد الاوكرانيه انطلاقه
سفينه محمله بالحبوب الى الصومال من موانئ
مدينه اوديسا جنوبيه اوكرانيا وقال نائب
رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني او الاكسندر كوبرا
كوف ان السفينه جزء من مبادره اطلقها
الرئيسكي بدعم من برنامج الاغذيه العالمي
لمساعده البلدان التي تعاني من الجوع يذكر
ان
533 سفينه محمله بمواد غذائيه اوكرانيه
الى دول اسيا واوروبا وافريقيا اغسطس
الماضي
المستشار الاقتصادي السابق للاتحاد
الاوروبي سيدروس هل هناك مؤشرات على تحقيق
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
تقدما في مسار تحديده سقف لسعر الغاز
الروسي
[موسيقى]
لم تجري مناقشات او لا تجري مناقشات معمقه
حول النفط او حفر حول الغاز الروسي لان
روسيا توقفت عن امداد اوروبا بالغاز
السؤال الكبير هو كيفيه حمايه المستهلكين
الاوروبيين من الاسعار المرتفعه
للغاز لقد تراجعت همم الاسعار ولكنها لا
تزال مرتفعه وايضا بنسبه الى فصل الشتاء
ما من مخاوف كبرى لان المخزون مرتفع وايضا
هناك محاولات لتوفير استهلاك الطاقه طبعا
ما من هلا ولكن في الوقت نفسه ما من اتفاق
بالنسبه الى سعر الغاز الروسي
كل من المانيا وهولندا فيما يتعلق بتحديد
سقف لسعر الغاز
سعر
الغاز لا تعرف ما الذي تريده بالضبط
تعتقد انه يمكنها ان تقول للمزودين
الاجانب يمكننا ان ندفع لكم كميه اقل من
الاموال ولكن هذا غير ممكن لان قطر
والجزائر والبرازيل واستراليا سوف تتوقف
في هذه الحاله عن ارسال الغاز الطبيعي
المثال باتجاه اوروبا اذا ما كانت اوروبا
ان تدفع اقل من اليابان وكوريا على سبيل
المثال لذلك المفوضيه الاوروبيه اقترحت
بان باي سقف للسعر يجب ان يكون على الاقل
نفس السعر المدفوع في اسيا وهذا ما تقدمت
به من مقترح المانيا وهولندا اذا همم من
المنظور اقتصاديه لا يمكن الدول الاوروبيه
ان تعتبر ان باستطاعتها ان تحدد سقف سعر
الغاز في العالم لذلك من غير المرجح ان
تحدد الدول الاوروبيه بالفعل سقف السعر
بالنسبه الخاصه
في تركيا في اسطنبول باعتقادك كيف يمكن ان
يتعامل معه دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
او خطه عريضه بعض الناس في بريكسال
المتوترون للغايه بهذا الخصوص يعتقدون ان
هذا الامر يمكن ان تستخدمه الروسيا لتخطي
العقوبات على حدودنا ولكن في حقيقه الامر
وفي الواقع معظم الخبراء لا يرون ان هذا
المركز سوف يؤدي الى تغيير الفعليه سوف
يتطلب الامر سنوات لكي تشييد تركيا هذه
الانابيب وايضا تركيا يتعين عليها ان تثبت
انها الشريك الاقتصادي الذي لديه استقرار
بشكل دائم ولكن تركيا تعاني من معادلات
تضخم مرتفعه وليس لديها نظام القض المستقل
المطلوب في حال وجود نزاعات تجاريه لذلك
معظم الخبراء برايهم نعم هذه الخطه موجوده
في تركيا ولكن من غير المراجحات ان تنفذ
شكرا دانيال لغروس المستشار الاقتصادي
السابق للاتحاد الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
فحص رئيسنا التركي والروسي ملف الشمال
السوري وسط استعداد انقره لعمليه عسكريه
بريه واسعه واستمرار قصفها مواقع وحدات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه والسنادا لبيان
الرئاسه التركيه فان الرئيس اردوغان ابل
الرئيس بوتين بضروره تطهير الحدود بين
المواصفهم بالارهابيين الى عمق 30 كلم
اتصال هاتفي للابقاء على التواصل بشان
الشمال السوري بين الرئيسين التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان
تفاهمات سابقه واخرى محل اخذ ورد بصيغتين
حسب رؤيه كل طرف للملف جاء بيان الرئاستين
التركيه والروسيه قالت انقر ان اردوغان
تحدث عن ضروره تطهير من وصفهم بالارهابيين
على طول الحدود الى عمق 30 كلم
مع اتفاق السوشي لعام 2019
واشرا ايضا الى استمرار مواصفاتها بلانشطه
الانفصاليه لحزب العمال الكردستاني ووحده
حمايه الشعب وحزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي في
شمال سوريا
على اساس اختفاء شروط الاتفاق الروسيه
التركي لعام 2019
والسياسه الخارجيه في البلدين ستواصل
لاتصالات الوثيقه في هذا الصدد على الارض
لا تعرف المدفعيه التركيه هدنه استهدفت
نقاط عسكريه لما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه تحديدا في قريه الطويله شمال
الحسكه وايضا نقاطا على امتداد الطريق
الدولي ام 4 في قريته عين عيسى بريف
الحسكه وتعرضت عده قرن غرب مدينه عين
العرب لقصف بطائرات مسيره
يبقى الوعيد التركي بشان عمليه بريه داخل
الشمال السوري رهن تجاذبات مع الحلفاء
والخصوم وسط اسرار الرئيس اردوغان على
تنفيذها عاجلا ام اجلا ويظل الملف بين
انقر ومسكو مرتبطا بملفات اخرى جديده
وقديمه قد يشمل الربط حرب روسيا في
اوكرانيا والتقارب المحتمله بين انقره
ودمشق ليس سرا ان بوتين يعارض اي عمليه
عسكريه تركيه لا تؤدي في نهايه المطاف الى
استفاده النظام السوري من الوضع ليحل مكان
قوه وحدات حمايه الشعب في المناطق التي
تطالب انقر باخلائها ثم ما هو مصير اتفاق
السوشي لعام 2019 والذي انهت بمشي به
تركيا عمليه نبعث السلام على الورق تعهدته
روسيا باخراج الوحدات الكرديه من طول
الحدود السوريه التركيه وبعمقه 33 كلم
مين نظري انقره لم تفهم بوعدها وهو ما
يخولها القيام بعمليه عسكريه جديده لحمايه
امنها القومي كما تقول عمليه تعرضها
واشنطن بالشده وترى انها ليست افضل وسيله
لمواجهه الخطر الذي يتعرض له الشعب التركي
تركيا والشمال السوري ملف مفتوح على كل
الاحتمالات هو ايضا الصفقات الدبلوماسيه
مع اكثر من طرف قريب وبعيد حلفا وخصم
علينا من موسكو يوري ماذا شاف مدير مركز
تركيا الجديده في موسكو ومن انقره محي
الدين عثمان الباحث في مركز سيتا للدراسات
سيد يوري هل تقلص الاتصالات بين الرئيسين
التركي
والروسيا الاختلاف حول الوضع العسكري في
شمال سوريا
على الاقل منذ عام 2015 حتى قبل دخول
روسيا الى سوريا سوريا من
في الدول اصبحت لاعبين
اساسيين في المساله
وهناك علاقات قويه في نفس الوقت اعتقد ان
لا احد من الاطراف قد وصل الى النتيجه
افضل من الاخر سيد محي الدين مرت تركي على
المقترح الروسي الذي تقدم به وفد قبل ايام
في اسطنبول
بانسحاب قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه والابقاء
على ما تعرف بالاسايش
منضويه تحت
النظام السوري في هذه المنطقه
تركيا تركيا
وطلبت بشكل مستمر ان يتم تنظيف الحدود
التركيه من العناصر الارهابيه ولذلك طالب
تطبيق
ونحن نتحدث هنا عن خط احمر بالنسبه الى
تركيا هذا اولا ثانيا الحكومه السوريه
والنظام الاسد في هذه المرحله
كان يتعاود مع وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
في تلعفر وفي ايضا همم شرق الفرات
وبالتالي هذا الامر لن يغير الوضع الميدا
بالنسبه الى تركيا لان الجهتين كانت
تتعامل مع بعضهما البعض ضد المصالح
التركيه وبالتالي هذا امر لن يقبل به
المسؤولون الاتراك
اذا تركيا لن تقبل بوجود قوات الاسد في
المنطقه سيد جوري همم الرئاسه التركيه
تقول بان موسكو لن تطبق ما تم الاتفاق
عليه في سوتشي وهناك بند بانسحاب قوه
سوريا الديمقراطيه الى عمق 30 كلم كيف
تفهم موسكو هذا الاصرار التركي على همم
تنفيذ هذا البنك في الاتفاقيه
نونا
يجب ان نفهم ان المساله الكرديه اذا كنا
نتحدث عن التسليح غير القانوني والتشكيلات
العسكريه او المقاتلين اذا كنا نستطيع ان
نسميهم بهذه الطريقه
وهذه مساله
ساخنه كما قلت من المفهوم ان هذه المناطق
التي يعيش بها الاكراد اعني هنا شمال
سوريا او جنوب تركيا
وهذه اجزاء من ايران من العراق
هذه المناطق التي يمكن ان تنظر ان فيها
موارد طبيعيه غنيه جدا من ان النفط والغاز
وهذا موضوع الطرق بين هذه المناطق الكثير
من النزاعات في تلك المنطقه الحاده جدا بل
هناك مجموعه من همم المصالح بين مختلف
الاطراف اعتقد ان بين تركيا وروسيا الان
هناك فرصه اكبر للارتفاع اكثر من ما كان
في السابق
كان هناك موقف
روسي ولكنه ضعيف في سوريا الان وهذا شيء
واضح لان همم
روسيا مهتمه
بقواتها العسكريه حتى تنضم الى المعارك في
اوكرانيا التي تسمى بالعمليه العسكريه
الخاصه لذلك هذه امور واضحه جدا للجميع
ويجب ان نفهم ان العلاقه بين بشار وبين
رئيس الروسي همم بوتين هي علاقه ايضا همم
يغطيها الغمام وهي علاقه ليست جيده كما
يعلم الكثير هناك ايضا الاثر الايراني
الذين همم
الاثر الايراني على العلاقات بين روسيا
وسوريا واعتقد ان الان هناك فرص للاتفاق
بين الطرف التركي والروسي سيد محي الدين
اذا كان هناك فرصه للاتفاق بين الطرفين
الروسي والتركي كما يقول السيد يوري ليست
مشكله تركيا مع اصدقائها وحلفائها ايضا
مثل الولايات المتحده التي ترفض رفضا تاما
اي عمليه عسكريه في الشمال السوري
جنوب انفوش الحقيقه
الى الازمه السوريه تشعر تركيا بانها اقرب
في موقفها الى الاتحاد الروسي منه الى
الحلفاء على مستوى حلف شمال الاطلسي
والسوق الحظ الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وعدد كبير من الحلفاء الغربيين لتركيا لم
ياخذوا المخاوف الامنيه التركيه على محمل
الجدوى اصروا على دعم القوات الكرديه قوات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه وهي امتداد لحزب
العمال الكردستاني والفعل نفسه هم يدعمون
حزب العمال الكردستاني ضد تركيا اما
الجانب الروسي بالنسبه الى هذه المساله
فقد اعرب عن تفهم من اكبر من المخاوف
الامنيه التركيه لذلك من العملي ان تت هنا
تركيا نتوصل الى اتفاق مع روسيا اكثر من
الولايات المتحده شكرا لكم محي الدين
اتمنى الباحث في مركز سيتا للدراسات في
انقره ويوري ماذا شاف مدير مركز تركي
الجديده في موسكو
[موسيقى]
تصعد التوتر في شمال كوسوفو بعدما تبدل
مهاجمون مجهولون اطلاق النار مع الشرطه
والقنبله صوتيه على شرطيين من بعثه
الاتحاد الاوروبي في الايام الماضيه
تفجيرات واطلاق نار وهجوم استهدف دوريه
للشرطه وشهدت الاسابيع الماضيه تصاعدا
للتوتر بين الاقليه الصربيه وحكومه
بريشتينا وعلى خلفيه التوتر ردود فعل
متتاليه من حيث الشمال الاطلسي والاتحاد
الاوروبي واشنطن بينماس الرئيس الصربي
اجتماعا لمجلس الامن القومي
وستوتر
اعلانات مهمه الاتحاد الاوروبي للتحقق من
سيره القانوني
بتسير دوريات الامن في شمال البلاد اعلنت
ان قنبله صوتيه القيت على احدى مركباتها
المدرعه دون ان تسفر عن اصابات مسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف
حذر من ان الاتحاد لن يتسامح مع العنف ضد
افراد بعثته وكتب على تويتر يجب ان تزيل
جماعات السرب كوسوفو الحواجز على الفور
يجب اعاده الهدوء نائبه رئيس الوزراء
وزيره الخارجيه في كوسوفو دونك
ردت فورا على هذه التصريحات بالقول انه
يجب على ايضا ادانه اطلاق النار على شرطه
كوسوفو اثناء اداء واجبها التصريحات التي
لا تدينه
بي عدوانه العلني تشجع على المزيد من
التصعيد بعد ساعات على نصب الحواجز قررت
كوسوفو تاجير الانتخابات التي كانت مقرره
في 18 من هذا الشهر الى 23 من ابريل
تصاعد التوتر بين البلدين الجارين كان
وراءه محاوله حكومه بريشتينا مطالبه سرب
كوسوفو باستبدال لوحات السيارات القديمه
القديمه من صربي المجاوره بلوحات من اصدار
كوسوفو وعلى الرغم من اعلان كوسوفو
استقلالها عن صربيا عام 2008 لا تعترف
بالجراج بهذه الخطوه وتشجع الاغلبيه
الصربيه في شمال كسوفو على تحدي سلطات
بريشتنا
الينا ديانا بريشا مديره منتدى المبادرات
المدنيه سيده ديانا كيف تفهمون توقيت
تصاعد التوتر في شمال كسوف
ذا النور
في كوسوفو بالاضافه الى الهيئات المختلفه
واستخدمت هذه الطرق من قبل المجرمين في
شمال
لتبرير الحواجز الميدانيه غير القانونيه
بالاضافه الى تبرير التهديدات الموجهه الى
سلطات كوسوفو وايضا الجهات الدوليه
اريد ان اقول اننا نتعامل مع صربيا صربيا
هي التي شنت خمسه حروب في التسعينيات
وقامت بالتطهير العرقي والابادات الجماعيه
للمجموعات الالبانيه في كوسوفو
والنخبه السياسيه الحاليه في صربيا هي
امتداد
ليس ليس معنى طرف صربي ليرد على هذه
الاتهامات ولكن نريد ان نفهم بتقيمكم ما
ما الالات هذا التصعيد
الى مالاتي التصعيد
قطع صوت الضيفه
اذا بنسبه الى اصدقاء كوسوفو
الدول التي تدعو على مستوى اوروبا لتيسير
حوار نحن بحاجه الى الجلوس الى الطاوله
وتفسير الامور التي
نواجهها كوسوفو السلام ولكن من جهه اخرى
تهدد بالحرب هناك طلب من قبل حكومه صربيا
لادخال قوات العسكريه باذن من حلف شمال
الاطلسي الى كوسوفو نحن نطالب
بالسلام ونود ان يتم الاعتراف باستقلال لا
اكثر ولا اقل هذا ما نستحقه
وانت وانت
23 عمل من
الحرب في منطقه البلقان ها نحن نتعرض
لتهديدات مجددا من قبل جيراننا
اود ان اشدد كوسوفو لا تود سوى الحوار
والاعتراف الكامل
معلقه بشكل يهدد الامن في بلادنا
وايضا يؤثر سلبا على صورتنا كدوله
مستقله شكرا لك
قال وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان ان من حق الدول الخليجيه ضمانه
امنها بما يتناسب مع تطورات التسليحي في
المنطقه واضاف وزير الخارجيه السعوديه انه
في حال حصول ايران على سلاح النووي فان
الدول الخليجيه ستسعى بلا شك الى ضمان
امنها وقال انه في حال عدم التوصل الى
اتفاق نووي مع ايران فان المنطقه ستدخل في
مرحله معقده جدا سيكون من الصعب جدا
تجنبها
وهي فاضيه
عيونك
من الايرانيين هو انهم غير مهتمين ببرنامج
اسلحه النوويه سيكون من المريح تصديق ذلك
ونحتاج الى المزيد من التطمينات اذا لم
يتم التوافق على استئناف الاتفاق النووي
فاننا سندخل مرحله بالغه التعقيد والخطوره
في منطقتنا
سته مدنين وجرح 17 اثر اطلاق نار من جانب
قوه حرس الحدود الافغاني وجاء في بيان
عسكري ان الحادثه وقع اليوم في بلده شامان
الحدوديه ان حرس الحدود الافغاني استخدموا
اثناء استهدافهم من المدنيين مدافعون كما
ذكر البيان ان قوه الجيش الباكستاني رده
بالمثل على مصادر اطلاق النار وانها تجنبت
اهداف المدنيه
اغلقت الحدود بين البلدين عده ساعات قبل
ان تفتح لاحقا
طالم
ا وقد نقل مراسل الجزيره في افغانستان عن
مصدر حكومي ان اشتباكات وقعت بين القوات
الافغانيه والباكستانيه قرب معبر سبيل
سبيل بلدك جنوبيه افغانستان واضاف المصدر
وان الاشتباكات وقعت على خلفيه اقامه
القوات الافغانيه نقطه حراسه جديده على
الحدود بين البلبلدين
اكتوبر
[موسيقى]
بعد عزل رئيس الياسمين بدر كاستيو
واعتقاله بتهمه محاوله الانقلاب على
الدستور وتسلمت دينارتي نائبه الرئيس
المعزول مهمه حكم البلاد وتشكيل الحكومه
مؤيدي الرئيس المعزول في المطالبه
بالافراج عنه وتنظيم انتخابات مبكرا
للمره العاشره على التوالي وخلال اربع
سنوات فقط تتشكل حكومه جديده
في تاريخ البلاد 17 وزيرا من الاختصاصيين
الدولي من الدستوريه في محاوله لتجنب مصير
الحكومات السابقه الذي اقيلت او استقالت
نتيجه ازمه الحكم المعقده
التي يعاني منها وطننا وقد اتينا اليكم
نمد ايدينا للعمل على ايجاد حل واستعاده
الاستقرار
منذ لحظه ولادتها لم تسلم هذه التشكيله
الحكوميه من الانتقادات في شكلها واسمائها
رغم اتفاق البيروفيين على انها جنبت
البلاد الفراغ
في الوقت الذي اعلنت فيه الحكومه الجديده
في البروج يرى مؤيد الرئيس المعزول بدر
كاسيو ان الخطوه تزيد من تعقيد المشهد
السياسي ويوصلنا احتجاجاتهم في العاصمه
وعموم البلاد رفضا لاجراءات رئيسه المؤقته
المطالبه بالاعلان عن تنظيم الانتخابات
مبكرا
عند ساحه الاحتجاجات الرئاسيه وسط العاصمه
ليما تخط انالي املهما في مستقبل مختلف
لبلدهما
نحن شباب نريد ان تسود الديمقراطيه بلدنا
نريد اجراء انتخابات مبكرا وتغيير
البرلمان الذي لا يشبهنا ولا يمثلنا
يؤيدها في ذلك محتجون من مختلف الاعمار
يرفعون مطالبا مشابها ويتوعدون بالاحتكام
الى الشارع ما لم يتم تنفيذها واولها
الافراج عن رئيسهم معتقل ما يضع البلاد
امام سيناريوهات مختلفه براي مختصين
التي تضم اختصاصيين كثيرا من حل المشكلات
المريحه للمواطنين فتستمر ويسود الاستقرار
اما الثاني فهو استمرار هذه الاحتجاجات
وتوسعها لتسقط الحكومه ونعود للمربع صفر
الذي قد يحتاج الى اعاده النظر في الدستور
اسباب ازمات البلاد ومصيرها باتت على كل
لسان هنا يتبادلها هؤلاء الاراء حول
واقعهم ويتمنون الا تفرقهم السياسه
اصبحت لدينا عاده الا يستطيع الرؤساء
الاستمرار وهذا كله بسبب الفساد نحتاج الى
استعاده الثقه فقط فقدنا الثقه فيه
ان خورخي فيتابع اخر اخبار بلده بقلق وارى
ان الحل يكمن في تغيير العقليه السياسيه
يتمنى البيروفيون ان تنتهي نغمه عزل
واستقاله الرؤساء اعل البهجه تعود الى
حياه سكان بلاد حضاره الانكا من جديد حسن
مسعود الجزيره ليما
قال اطباء بريطانيون ان طفله مصابه بسرطان
الدم اللمفاوي الحاد تعافت بعد اضاعها
لعلاج جديد يستخدم الخلايا المناعيه
المعدله وراثيا واجريت التجربه السريريه
في مستشفى للاطفال في لندن وقال الفريق
الطبي انه تفتح افاقا
لعلاج ذلك النوع الفتاك من سرطان الدم
المنتشر بين الاطفال
فتح علمي رائد سرعان ما اصبح قصه نجاح
مبشره لمرضى سرطان الدم من الاطفال
لقد تمثلت اليسا الفتاه البريطانيه
البالغه 13 عاما من سرطان الدم اللمفاوي
الحاد الذي اصيبت به العام الماضي
بعد ان اخفقت العلاجات التقليديه من اشعه
كيميائيه وزرع لنخاع العظم في تعافيها
خضعت الفتاه لتجربه سريريه في مستشفى
لندن حيث استخدم فريق الاطباء خلايا
مناعيه معدله وراثيا ماخوذه من متطوع سليم
وهي اليه علاج تسمى التحويل الكيميائيه
لاحرف في شيفره الحمض النووي
بعد اربعه اسابيع من التجربه الواعده لاحظ
الفريق الطبي ان وضع اليسا اصبح مستقرا
مما اتاح اخضاعها ثانيه لعمليه زرع نخاع
عظمي لاعاده عمل جهازها المناعي
وبمضي سته اشهر صار وضع الفتاه جيدا وعادت
الى منزلها مع تلقيها متابعه طبيه
اليسا وهي اول مريضه يعلن عن اسمها
كمتلقيه للخلايا التائيه المعدله اعتبر
اطباءها ان خضوعها للعلاج التجريبي كان
خيارا وحيدا امامها بدل الاكتفاء برعايه
تسكينيه ضد هذا الداء الذي يعد من اكثر
انواع السرطانات شيوعا وفتكا بين الصغار
الانجاز الطبي الجديد الذي يفتح افاقا
مستقبليه واعده جاء بعد تجارب سابقا انتهت
عام 2015 الى الفشل لكن العلماء واصلوا
البحث عن حلول بديله عملا بالقاعده
القائله ان تاريخ العلم هو تاريخ اخطاء
العلم
[موسيقى]
فقره المتابعه في حصاد الليله نصلي فيها
الضوء على المشهد الميداني في اوكرانيا
والبدايه من الوضع في الجنوب بعد هجوم
الروسيه اكثر من مليون و500 الف شخص بدون
كهرباء في اوديسا بحسب تصريحات الرئيس
الاوكراني هذا التطور اثار قلقا بشان
ثلاثه مواني على البحر الاسود في منطقه
يودسه يعول عليها في تصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه في الجنوب ايضا تحديدا في
خيرسون يقولوا حاكمها انها تعرضت لقصف
الروسيه اثر على شبكه الكهرباء وامداد
المياه في منطقه الجنوبيه قصفت القوات
الاوكرانيه مدينه الاستراتيجيه التي تسيطر
عليها القوات الروسيه وفي الشرق تحديدا
افادت مراسله الجزيره ان وسط المدينه تعرض
لقصف اوكرانيا الحق اضرار بالبنيه التحتيه
وايضا ببعض المنشات الحديث عن دنياز
والقصفه الروسي لخط المواجهه في الشرق
جدداء التساؤلات عن الاهداف الروسيه في
الحرب التي تقترب من اكمال شهرها العاشر
ففي الرابع والعشرين من فبراير شباط
الماضي اطلقت روسيا ما سمتها انا ذاك
عمليه عسكريه خاصه وقالت انها لا تعتزم
احتلال اراضا اوكرانيه لكن في اكتوبر
تشرين الاول اعلنت روسيا انها ضمت اربع
مناطق هي دنياك لوجانس ذا فروجيا واخرسون
ايضا بعد اجراء استفتاءات الى رفضتها
اوكرانيا والغرب الخميس الماضي قال الكريم
انه عاصم على تامين الجزء الاكبر من
الاراضي في شرق اوكرانيا وجنوبها على
الاقل ويبدو انه تخلى عن الاستيلاء على
اراضي اخرى في الوسط والشمال الشرقي كانت
اوكرانيا قد استعادتها ماذا عن اهداف
اكياس يكرر الرئيس الاوكراني برده قول ان
قوته ستتمكن في النهايه
من ترضي روسيا من كل الاراضي التي سيطرت
عليها بما في ذلك شبه جزيره القرمه التي
ضمتها موسكو عام 2014 نظام الينا من عمان
اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي اللواء الدويري بعد 10 اشهر
من الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا كيف ترى ما
تحقق حتى الان بنسبه للطرفين
هو انجاز بالنسبه للجانب الاوكراني لانه
القراءات الاولى والتسريبات الاولى
والتصريحات حتى والتقديرات من السي اي ايه
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه ان الحرب سيكون
عمدها فقط 96 ساعه ثم ظهرت تقارير لاحقا
خلال الاسبوع الماضي كذلك همم ايضا من
الشيعه ايه بناءا على معلومات من محيط
الرئيس بوتين ان القراءه الاولى كانت
تتوقع ان يتم حسم الامر خلال عشره ايام
فها هو الان بدل كل يوم شهر ولم تنتهي
الحرب اثنين كانت القراءات ان الجيش
الاوكراني الذي يستطيع الصمود وبالتالي
التوجيه السياسي كان يتحدث عن
السيطره على اوكرانيا همم نزع النازيه
التخلص من المنظومه السياسيه الى غير ذلك
اذا دعني اقول ان مجرد صمود
الاوكرانيا سواء القياده السياسيه او
العسكريه لهذا العمل من من الزمن اا ضد
ثاني جيش في العالم يعتبر شيء ايجابي وحتى
ان مستوى الخطاب السياسي ال- في البدايه
كان مستعد
للعوده الى اتفاقيه ماسك ولكن الان
المطالبه كما شرط انه يطالب بالقرم ليس
فقط للمناطق الاربعه بالنسبه للجانب
الروسي
قياسا مع قدراته العسكريه الكامله في
ابعادها البشريه والمعدات وغير ذلك لا
تعرضت الى انتكاسات وحتى اكثر المحللين
تشاما لم يكن يتوقع سوء اداره المعركه
الروسيه بهذا الشكل لماذا لانه استنادا
الى التسريبات طيب
ومقارنتها بالمجريات نجد انهم فشلوا في في
كيف في خارف في خيرسون وبالتالي
لا اقول استنفدت كامل طاقات ولكنها
استخدمت اقصى طاقات ممكن ولم تحقق النتائج
المرجوه فهمنا منك بان الاهداف الروسيه
تبدلت هل لهذا انعكاسات على المسار
السياسي في وقت الان تتوافر فيها
التصريحات الغربيه المطالبه بوضع حد للحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا
يعني الان اذا اذا اخضعنا خطاب الرئيس
جالينسكي
واعتمدناك اساس هذا الوقت ليس وقت مفاوضات
لماذا لانه هناك اقليم دومباس اجزاء كبيره
من زابارودها من خيرسون بقايا من مايكو
لايف همم تحت الاحتلال الروسي وبالتالي
الذي يحسم الاتفاقي اي حرب تنتهي بالتوافق
بالتفاوض ولكن المفاوضات
مرتكزها الاساسي الواقع الميداني الواقع
الميداني موجود النظر الاوكرانيه هناك
اربعه مناطق محتله وعلى القرم تعتبر رقم
خمسه اذا هذا الوقت
امتثالا لتوجهات القياده الاوكراني هو ليس
وقت التفاوض لانها لم تحقق ما يجب
لو سمحت بدقيقه اذا كيف تفهم هذا الضغط
الغربي
بمعزل ما يحصل على الارض بدقيقه واحده
السبب المعاناه في قبل فصل الشتاء وخوف
الانظمه السياسيه الغربيه بان مشكله الغاز
والنفط
مضاجع هذه الشعوب وهذه الشعوب تقول ان
هذهمقراطيه ويمكن ان تسقط هذه الحكومات
وبالتالي هي تزرع الخطر عن نفسها ولو على
حساب الطموح الاكراني شكرا لك اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري واستراتيجي في
عمان
[موسيقى]
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه اليكم
الانباء قبل الانتقال الى الجوله الرياضيه
يوميات المونديال قال الجيش الاوكراني ان
القوات الروسيه نفذت 17 ضربه جويه واكثر
من 60 هجوما صاروخيا على اوكرانيا
اكثر من 170 صاروخا وقذيفه اوكرانيه
استاذه مناطق سكنيه التحتيه
قال رئيس الاوكراني انه بحث في اتصال مع
نظيره الفرنسي تعاون في مجالي الدفاع
والطاقه الى جانب النقاط العشري لتحقيق
السلام وفقا لصيغه الاوكرانيه وحذر وزير
الخارجيه البريطاني من استغلال محادثات
السلام في اوكرانيا غطاء لاعاده تسلح
روسيا
قال المتحدث باسم الكرملين لان نتجاهل
الهواجس الروسيه بشان اتفاقات منسك شكل
مقدمه لما وصفهها بالعمليه العسكريه
الخاصه في اوكرانيا جاءته قال نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي لمتر مدفادف ان عدوه
روسيا ليس في قياس بل في اوروبا وامريكا
الشماليه واليابان واستراليا ونيوزيلندا
وغيرها
بحث الرئيس التركي ومع نظيره الروسيه
المصالح المشتركه في مجال الطاقه وانشاء
مركز اقليبيا في اسطنبول لتصدير الغاز في
المقابل اعرب منسق سياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي عن قلق الاتحاد مما
وصفها بسياسه تركيا في عدم انضمام
للاجراءات التقليديه الاوروبيه ضد روسيا
اكد رئيس التركي في اتصال مناظيره روسي
ضروره تطهير الحدود مع سوريا بعمق 30 كلم
ممن سماهم الارهابيين وافادت مصادر محليه
للجزيره بان القوات التركيه قصفت نقاط
عسكريه ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
في قريه الطويل بمحيطه تلتمر شمل الحسد
تصاعد التوتر في شمال كسوف والاحد بعد ان
تبادل مجهولون اطلاق النار مع الشرطه
والقوا قنبله صوتيه على شرطيين من بعثه
الاتحاد الاوروبي وحذر مفوض سياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزه بريل
من هجمات محتمله على البعثه الاوروبيه
اذا نهايه الحصاد شكرا لكم على حسن متابعه
الى اللقاء بامان الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]